so you think all the magic of the human
mind comes from this just a few pounds
of mush
of a biological computational mush
that's
akin to some of the neural networks
not directly but in spirit that uh deep
mind has been working with
well look i think it's um you say it's a
few you know of course it's this is the
i think the biggest miracle of the
universe is that um it is just a few
pounds of mush in our skulls and yet
it's also our brains are the most
complex objects in the in that we know
of in the universe so there's something
profoundly beautiful and amazing about
our brains and
i
think that it's an incredibly uh
incredible efficient machine and and uh
uh
and it's you know phenomenal basically
and i think that building ai one of the
reasons i want to build ai and i've
always wanted to is i think by building
an intelligent artifact like ai and then
comparing it to the human mind um that
will help us unlock the uniqueness and
the true secrets of the mind that we've
always wondered about since the dawn of
history like consciousness dreaming
creativity uh uh emotions what are all
these things right we've we've wondered
about them since since the dawn of
humanity and i think one of the reasons
and you know i love philosophy and
philosophy of mind is we we found it
difficult is there haven't been the
tools for us to really other than
introspection to from very clever people
in in history very clever philosophers
to really investigate this
scientifically but now suddenly we have
a plethora of tools firstly we have all
the neuroscience tools fmri machines
single cell recording all of this stuff
but we also have the ability computers
and ai to build uh intelligent systems
so i think that um
uh
you know i think it is amazing what the
human mind does and um and and
i'm kind of in awe of it really and uh
and i think it's amazing that with our
human minds we're able to build things
like computers and and actually even you
know think and investigate about these
questions i think that's also a
testament to the human mind yeah the
universe built the human mind that now
is building computers that help
us understand both the universe and our
own human mind right that's exactly it i
mean i think that's one you know one
could say we we are maybe we're the
mechanism by which the universe is going
to try and understand itself
you